i say 32 years because way back when i
was a student at the university of
florida
i was a member of students for biden in
1988 and
wore my biden for president button on my
backpack
all over campus and so the thrill and
the opportunity
to thank you all for joining us today
here in pembroke pines
and welcome our next president joe biden
to
our district and our community here in
south florida is just
absolutely amazing because the stakes in
this election
are so high for all of us but for our
seniors
it's all about family health
safety and survival we have witnessed
an epic failure by donald trump to
confront and manage
this pandemic just look at our lives
right now
look at the gathering we're in the midst
of
grandparents can't safely see or hug
their kids or their grandkids
we've had more than fifteen thousand
needless funerals
here in the state of florida funerals
which by the way we can't fully attend
as families
because this virus isn't truly under
control
our economy which is so tied to travel
and leisure is being ravaged
and from the beginning trump has failed
to take it seriously
leaving a record of death deceit and
denial in his wake
worse he left seniors to fend for
themselves with no plan to contain this
deadly virus
even when trump manages to respond to
this crisis
he's put seniors in more danger about
one in three
floridians rely on florida about one in
three older floridians
rely on social security as a sole source
of their income
and over four and a half million count
on medicare
yet donald trump's executive orders
threaten the survival
and stability of these critical programs
make no mistake
neither of these men will walk into the
white house without the blessing
of florida's seniors am i right yes
there's no question about that much is
made in the rise of the youth vote and
thank god for it
but it is residents who are 65 and older
who still swing elections
here in the sunshine state there's no
doubt about that
the road to the white house travels
through florida
and about three quarters of our seniors
turn up at the polls
every single election so while trump
closes down the government's pandemic
strike force
lies to americans about the threat that
it poses or pushes another quack cure
joe biden actually has a plan to get
covert 19 under control
and for the long term security of our
seniors joe biden has a plan
that actually strengthens social
security compared to just a few weeks
ago
when shockingly donald trump made it
clear he would shred the funding
mechanism
for this vital safety net for our
seniors you just can't make this stuff
up this man wants to try to win florida
and he would shred
that vital safety net joe biden rightly
says
this is a battle for the soul of our
nation
and there is no question about that and
in that battle joe biden
will not allow vital programs like
social security fall victim to this
virus
it is the life-saving program for
millions of american senior citizens
so let me be very clear joe biden won't
sacrifice social security
or threaten the future of medicare to
slay this virus like trump has already
proposed
joe biden will protect social security
with all the political muscle he can
muster
the inadequate response to the
coronavirus pandemic has caused a crisis
in our nursing homes and long-term care
facilities
as trump continues to sit on his hands
joe biden released a plan to increase
safety
oversight and transparency so our loved
ones can be cared for with the dignity
that they deserve
when it comes to protecting medicare or
lowering prescription drug costs
you know joe biden will go to bat for
florida seniors
because he's done it all his life
protecting seniors
isn't just some reality show gimmick and
joe biden that joe ryden trots out for
cameras one day
and then moves on from the next day
protecting seniors
is who joe biden is it's who he's always
been
from the villages in central florida to
century village sunrise lakes and kings
point here in broward county
in their heart of hearts our seniors
know that they can truly count on joe
biden
they can count on joe biden to protect
social security preserve medicare
and make their medications less
expensive and more affordable
and deep down seniors know they can
count on joe biden to take down this
virus
and safely reunite them with their
friends children and grandchildren
florida seniors know they have a friend
and ally and joe biden because he's
always stood by them
and even in a crisis like this one he'll
never leave their side
and that trust will show itself on
election day
it already is i just know it 21 days my
friends
on to victory for florida for florida's
seniors
and for all of america thank you so much
my
please welcome former western city
commissioner
toby foyer
hello broward county my name is toby
foyer
i was born in the bronx and grew up in
new york city i got married and had two
wonderful children
i worked for 25 years at brooklyn
college in administration
and moved here to broward county in 1998
to allegedly retire
well it wasn't much of a retirement for
me
i immediately became involved with my
condo association
and my local community and i served
eight years
on the western city commission
i like to call myself a professional
volunteer
i work with automerica the western music
society
western friends of the library hadasta
and the american association of
university women
to name just a few in short i like to
stay busy
we always hear people say this is the
most important
election of our lifetimes but for
florida seniors this
really is the most important election we
will
ever vote in like so many seniors i paid
into social security
for my entire life and i plan my
retirement
around that income but now donald trump
is threatening to defund
social security some of my neighbors
depend on social security as their sole
source of income and for a president
to break his promise to us is
unconscionable
especially now in the middle of a
pandemic
before covin 19 and my weeks were jammed
with
with so many things meetings social
gatherings
trips and so much more but then
everything changed
proven 19 has turned my life upside down
meetings are over consumed now and i try
to keep in touch with friends over the
phone
but it's simply not the same
i am incredibly fortunate to be living
with my daughter who works from home
but i don't ever leave my house unless
it's to purchase groceries
and essentials every two weeks
the simple truth is i didn't have it
didn't have to be this bad
none of us want to live our lives at
home in front of the computer screen
and if donald trump hadn't lied to us
and if he had decided to take this virus
seriously
things might be different for florida
seniors
but this administration has written
seniors off as expendable
well guess what we aren't
and we vote the president has been a
disaster
for seniors we deserve better
we deserve a leader who cares about
us i know joe biden will look out for us
i know joe will protect and strengthen
social security
and i know he will lower the cost of
prescription drugs
and i know that he has a real plan to be
covered 19 so that our friends and
neighbors we could see them again
our kids our grandkids and get life
back to normal as soon as possible
joe biden will always fight the seniors
and that's why i encourage you and
ask you to please get out to vote
either by mail or in person for joe
biden and kamala harris
to be our next president and vice
president
of the united states thank you so much
makes me wanna holler the way they do my
life
please welcome the next president of the
united states
joe biden
hello hello hello
good to see you all please please take a
seat if you have one
thank you so very very much for it's
good to be back in florida
and uh i want to thank my good friend
debbie wasserman-schultz congresswoman
she's been a tireless fighter
where's david there she is thank you
debbie you've been a friend a long time
and
thank you for uh all the encouragement
and uh
toby i also want to thank you uh toby
moved from a high rent district in
brooklyn
that's the highest rentistic in america
right now these days
boy man good to see you and i want to
thank you for that kind of introduction
and it's wonderful to be here with with
all of you to hear
the stories talk about how we're going
to get through these
tough times difficult times today's uh
today's story is a familiar one here in
south florida
uh we're all in we're all living some
version of
it right now with some of the most
important parts of our lives being put
on
hold and uh the same story being lived
by people uh
like uh like carl scheckter who many of
you
uh know well carl's here today i'm told
i don't know
all right hey carl how are you man good
to see you
the light was shining right in my eyes
looking at you man i apologize
carl is uh 39 years old no
93 years old but he acts like he's 39
years old
and the pillar of this community so much
so that a few years back you all decided
to rename this community center in his
honor
i've heard wonderful things about you
carl and looking forward to saying hello
to you privately
you know i had the pleasure of meeting
carl back in 2012. he may not remember
it but uh
his story is what this community and
this country is all about
carl is the son of an immigrant carl
served our nation honorably
in the second world war and met as
sweetheart anita when they were they've
been married now for 67 years
together they built a family four
children seven grandchildren
and uh more than 30 years they made home
here
staying engaged in all the local issues
and holding local office
catching sunday matinees and performance
at the art center and the center and
socializing with neighbors enjoying
nights in the town and a couple times
two three times a week going out
and uh but but their story like so many
others is a quintessential american
story these days
it was but has been erupted this year
carl
and anita haven't been out i'm told to a
restaurant in seven months
and they're no more sunday matinees
other than getting groceries they spend
most of their time
in their apartment like so many people
do it's harder than ever to spend time
with the people you love
other than on zoom or on a computer
connection
uh we've all felt that sense of
interruption in our lives
and we all know that this this isn't
normal
that things didn't have to be this bad
they didn't have to be this bad
we look around at our neighbors and we
know people are hurting
a lot of folks are worried about making
their next rent payment the next
mortgage payment
they're not only they uh whether or not
they can purchase their prescription
drugs or put
food on the table and we see awful lot
of people at the very top
doing better than they've ever done and
uh
left to wonder an awful lot of us is
who's looking out for me
who's looking out for me that's been his
story the entire story of my view of
donald trump's presidency
the fact that he's never been focused on
what matters
he's never been focused on you his
handling of this pandemic has been
erratic
just like his presidency has been and it
has
prevented florida seniors and people all
across the country
from getting the relief that they need
donald trump
hasn't just been willing to not do the
work
i think it's that beyond that i'm not
sure he cares about
delivering any real help i think it's
both that people say he's not willing to
do the work well i don't think he cares
much about it
while you're losing precious time with
your loved ones he's been stuck in a
sand trap in one of his golf courses
and when he does decide to lift a finger
it doesn't help you
it's to propose new tax cuts for
billionaires and i'm not that's not
hyperbole
that's not hyperbole 100 wealthiest
billionaires in america are expected to
get another 30 billion
tax cut he's proposing we know what
happened the last time a tax cut was
passed in 2019
after 2017 when he came into office
pharmaceutical companies got billions of
dollars in tax breaks
and then they turned around and raised
prices for medicines that you rely on to
stay healthy
and they're still doing it even during
the pandemic
and quite frankly it's unconscionable
but trump
doesn't really care about lowering the
health care costs because
he's beholden to health insurance
companies and the drug companies
after all he's asking the united states
supreme court as i speak
he's asking right now to strike down the
entire affordable care act
which would eliminate seniors ability
everyone most of you are a medicare
but it would eliminate your ability and
that act we passed by was able to help
put in
place was that you'd have preventative
services
and annual checkups and mammograms for
free under medicare
if it gets struck down that gets wiped
out as well
rise in prescription drug prices for
millions of seniors and putting medicare
for
trust fund at risk and by the way we
used to talk about the medicare trust
fund i say the republicans want to
eliminate it but remember debbie will
remember when
he's not a bad guy in terms of his
personality but when the former speaker
of the house
became speaker what'd they do they
proposed a half a billion dollars cut
in medicare from the start right off the
bat
these guys mean what they say this
president as
debbie pointed out his pledge to
terminate the tax
that's dedicated to financing social
security terminated
a social security actuary not joe biden
or a liberal think tank or a newspaper
this the actuary the social security
says
that would bankrupt social security in
just a few years
putting those monthly checks for tens of
millions of seniors
with the rely on the minimum the only
thing they rely on
at risk all this president knows how to
do
is play games with people's lives and
family's futures
last week he announced he was quote
walking away from the negotiations
that were never he never fully engaged
it like he's not walking away he never
fully engaged in him
to provide any additional relief for
american families
debbie working like the devil in the
house they passed
the heroes act they passed two other
pieces of legislation earlier
to provide for the ability to keep
people from going out of business
peak people bail or being kicked out of
their homes etc
he turned his back on small businesses
that are struggling to keep their doors
open
he turned his back on firefighters and
police officers and first responders
who depend on local budgets but local
budgets are being broken and they have
to be balanced
i'll just take make note here when we
inherited the largest
recession the greatest recession since
the depression
what happened president put me in charge
of the recovery act
800 billion dollars first thing i was
able to do and i was able to manage it
myself was that
put 147 billion dollars and help state
and local authorities
be able to balance their budgets not
have to fire police officers not have to
fire firefighters not to fire first
responders
not have to close down health clinics
local governments are strained to the
breaking point
he turned his back on educators and
school children
stand in the way of support to get them
ppe and cleaning supplies and
ventilation needed to reopen school
safely
which we could do if we funded it he
turned his back in every single worker
whose job hasn't come back
and now he says he wants a deal
one day he's tweeting that the relief
package is too big the next day he's
saying it's too small
it's all a game he thinks he's still on
his game show not really he acts that
way
for real this is a political game he's
playing his latest gimmick he wants to
mail seniors a 200 prescription
drug cash card with his name on it so
you're going to get it before election
with his name on it
but what he's going to do he's going to
raid medicare trust fund
to pay for that 200 which seniors have
already spent by paying money
into he thinks that he can take the
money
out of your pocket with one hand and put
it back with his name stamped on it on
the other hand
and call it a gift it's dishonest
it's reckless it doesn't actually help
anybody
in fact all they'll do is undermine the
medicare trust fund
and increase overall out-of-pocket costs
for seniors
let's be clear about this donald trump
has tried for almost
four years to lower he says he wants to
lower drug prices
okay but he hadn't done a single thing
to do it
in fact the house representatives passed
a bill debbie supported
that would bring down prescription drug
costs across the board
giving medicare the power
in washington medicare department the
power to negotiate
to negotiate with the drug companies and
say we're not if
if an aspirin is going to cost if
they're being charged they're making
this up
and if an aspect are going to cost two
two cents an aspirin they say we're only
going to pay a penny in aspirin
they're either going to do it or not
they're going to have to do it
we've been fighting to get debbie and i
and others been fighting to be able to
do this for years
it would lower drug prices what did
president trump do
he said if it passes he'll veto it
threaten to veto it folks donald trump's
chaotic and divisive leadership
has cost us far too much
215 000 dead from coba 19
and rising experts say
we'll lose nearly another 200 000 lives
in the next few months unless he
fundamentally changed course
you know i wish i prayed for his
recovery when he got covered
i hoped at least he'd come out of it
somewhat chastened
but what has he done he's just doubled
down on the misinformation he did before
in making it worse
so many lives have been lost unnecessary
because this president cares more about
the stock market than he does about
you know well-being of seniors one day
before we cross the threshold of 200
000 deaths you may recall this the
president was at the campaign rally
and the insistent that the virus was and
i quote
affects virtually nobody quote
just elderly people with heart and other
problems
nobody think about that
who was he talking about when he said it
affects virtually
nobody he's talking about america's
seniors
he was talking about you he's talking
about my family
you've worked hard your whole life
contributing to society
building the family building the country
serving america
you deserve security you deserve respect
and peace of mind
but you're not getting it by the way if
this wasn't
so bizarre you'd think you know if i
tried to make a movie talking about
something like this in america you think
i was making it up
because donald trump it's simple
not a joke you're expendable you're
forgettable
you're virtually nobody that's how he
sees seniors
that's how he sees you it's no surprise
this is the same man who looks at
americans who put their lives on the
line
like you did sir and many others maybe
in this room
for our nation and calls them losers and
suckers
i carry this card with me every day for
the last 15 years
and the bad it's my schedule in the back
of the schedule i have a black box
it says daily troupe update the number
of troops who died in iraq and
afghanistan
6924 not
roughly 6900 920 because every one of
these
fallen angels left a family behind
deserves to be remembered everyone
us troops wounded in iraq and
afghanistan
53 000 as of today 194.
everyone with only one sacred obligation
in america
to care for those we send to war and
equip them when they come home take care
of them and their families
and what did he say losers
my son volunteered to go to iraq for a
year
before that he had been in kosovo
for eight months best of my knowledge
the only foreigner has a
war monument and a major highway in that
country named after him
for his contributions helping them set
up their criminal justice system
then he volunteered to go to iraq as
attorney general for a year
my son was not a loser of all those who
left behind he's passed away but all
those left behind
they were heroes there are patriots
i imagine that's one of the reasons why
six four-star generals and a whole lot
of others have endorsed me who used to
work for him
because they know where his heart isn't
that's how he sees us that's the
attitude he's brought to this whole
crisis
this is the same man you may remember
when he was told we were averaging
1 000 lives lost per day
remember what he said he said it is what
it is
such concern and empathy it is what it
is it is what it is because
he is who he is
that's what israelis is
this president has debbie referenced
back in january when he was being
briefed by the intelligence community
he said i never read the briefing didn't
know it was in it
didn't have time well the assad because
ego
moved him to try to convince a famous
journalist to write something good about
him
what happened bob woodward interviewed
him
he acknowledged that he knew it was a
dangerous and highly communicable
disease
but he did nothing he didn't do a thing
he didn't tell you he didn't tell any
american
why he told woodward
on tape told bob board he didn't want to
panic the american public
americans don't panic
trump panics
his reckless personal conduct since his
diagnosis is unconscionable
the longer donald trump is president the
more reckless he seems to get
thank god we only have three weeks left
to go
dr fauci most respected doc
in the country on these issues you know
referred to the president's announcement
on the supreme court in the rose garden
using the white house
as a backdrop for political events
he said it was a super spreader event
how is trump responding he's running a
national ad
quoting dr fauci out of context
he had said way back in march
referring to public health officials
across the nation he said quote
i can't imagine anybody could be doing
more end of quote meaning public health
officials
if the trump campaign which is not
unusual because i've had a piece of it
trump campaign has deliberately lied
they have put dr fauci in their ad
asserting that fauci was talking about
trump
when he said couldn't have done anymore
but fauci is a man of integrity
after that ad came out saying
he said i did not give permission to use
that quote and i wasn't referring to the
president
even when after fauci said that he
didn't say that about the president
the trump ad campaign said they were
going to continue
to use the ad knowing
knowing it was a lie
can anybody remember anything like that
in a presidential campaign with a
mainstream
candidate and as a consequence
to months of line misleading
irresponsible action on the part of
donald trump
how many empty chairs are around the
dining room table the night
because of his negligence
how many people's hearts are broken
how many people have trouble going to
sleep at night
because they can't just reach over and
touch
they can't hear their son or daughter's
voice on the phone
while he throws super spreader parties
at the white house
where republicans hug each other without
concern of the consequences
how many of you been unable to hug your
grandkids
in the last seven months i got six of
them
two of them my deceased sons boys they
live not children boy and a girl
live not far from me they can walk
through the woods the only way i can see
them i stand on the back porch
and they stand down and we and i i bribe
them with
haagen-dazs bars but
i every single day i contact them
but i can't hug them i can't embrace
them
and i'm luckier than most because
they're nearby
those two of the six my grandkids
your grandkids who hope will grow up to
treat one others kindness
respect and empathy qualities the
president has never ever shown
it's become painfully clear as this
careless
arrogant reckless coped response has
caused one of the worst tragedies in
american history
the only senior that donald trump cares
about the only senior is
senior donald trump they don't seem to
do anything before and by the way
you know minority communities are
getting particularly hit by this
you realize as of about a month ago
on a percentage basis one in 1 000
african-americans in all america have
died
and the estimate is by the end of this
year one in 500
african-americans in america will die
one in 500.
if he doesn't do something quickly and
we hit 400 000
that is more people the same number of
people
that died in the war you fought or all
four years
400 000 dead
world war ii in less than a year
if he doesn't move
the only one donald trump will do
anything for is donald trump
look folks
we're so much better than this we can
contain this virus we can fully reopen
our
economy we can bring congress together
to pass real relief
and then implement a comprehensive
agenda to build back better
my my my economic proposal and by the
way it's not a
liberal thing banker democratic think
tank that says this an independent
analysis put up by moody's
a wall street firm projects that my
economic plan
will create 18.6 million good paying
jobs between now and the end of the
first term
seven million more jobs than the
president's plan
and create a trillion more dollars in
economic growth in the president's plan
it's solid it's real
here's how my plan works i'm not going
to raise taxes on a single solitary
american making less than 400
000 a year you won't pay a penny more
it's a guarantee
but i'm going to ask big corporations
and wealthy to begin to pay their fair
share to straighten out
the tax structure that money will allow
us to invest in working people and carry
with me i don't know i have it with me
now
i don't a card that lists all
what is in the tax code
we went ahead the president's tax plan
brock and i are suggesting we reduce
core protection 35
to 28. that was the consensus he reduced
it to 21.
you know how much that cost 1.3
trillion dollars we just take it back up
to 28.
it'll generate 1.3 trillion dollars more
91 of the fortune 500 companies don't
pay a penny in tax
not a single solitary cent if we made
sure there was a minimum tax of 15
that would add another 400 billion
dollars
we're going to take this money we're
going to invest in a working people
in a growing middle class and make sure
everyone is included in the deal
i want to actually reform the tax code
because we're spending your tax dollars
on the wrong things
as i said donald trump trump
cut the tax from 35 to 21.
costing the treasury a fortune as i said
if we raise it back to 28
1.3 trillion dollars will come to the
treasury over the next decade
instead of giving big corporations
hundreds of billions in
to pay for buyback and buying back their
own stock
moving jobs overseas we should invest in
cures for cancer
diabetes alzheimer's and parkinson's
that's why i proposed giving the
nationalist two to health
50 billion dollars over the next four
years to go after cancer
diabetes alzheimer's and parkinson's if
we do not and no
drug company has the capacity to do it
if we do not
find an answer to alzheimer's within the
next
19 years every single solitary bed that
exists in the united states of america
now will be occupied by alzheimer's
patient
look my dad used to have an expression
he said joey if everything's equally
important to you
nothing's important to you you have to
have priorities
what are our priorities our priorities
are to make sure
that everybody in america has an equal
shot
this is about you it's about what's fair
it's about what our priorities should be
and we can deal with the scourge of
cancer
and these other diseases but donald
trump has no interest
in facts he wants to do the opposite he
proposes more tax cuts for the super
wealthy
like donald trump we're going to ease
the burden on major costs
in your life unlike him including a
financial burden of caregiving so many
families are now carrying
right now as you probably know and you
have friends 800 000 americans
who are eligible for home community care
through medicaid
signed up for it have been waiting an
average of five years
they're waiting for a phone call back
for some
for some five years my plan makes a bold
investment so the states can clear the
waiting list
we'll also take the pharmaceutical
companies we'll allow medicaid to
again use its enormous bargaining power
to negotiate prices for
and bring costs down for everyone not
just seniors
give all americans access to those lower
prices
and what he also hates my doing is so do
the drug companies
we're going to establish a board like as
in other countries of outside experts to
set limits on the price's new specialty
drugs that are life-saving drugs that
cost
an arm and a leg figuratively and
literally
that have no competition this board is
going to set up and say
this is how much you can charge based on
what you've invested
you make a healthy profit but you will
not be able to raise the price of the
drug without proof that you've taken
other action
that you've required you to improve the
drug
so it can only be raised in the cost of
medical inflation
independent analysis found that my plan
will slash the cost of prescription
drugs
by 60 how many of you know somebody
who's had to
sell things just to get the drugs that
have gone up exponentially
we're going to protect social security
and increase benefits for millions of
seniors
i'll fight to protect your pensions
including fixing fixing
mulder employer pensions so many
floridians earned and deserved
folks i guess once you're done with this
i'm confident i know as bad as things
are
saying oh my god how can it get better i
am absolutely confident we can do this
and more
we just have to come together i'm
running as a proud democrat
but i'm going to govern as an american
president
i'm going to work as hard for those who
vote against me
as those who voted for me
that's the job of a president a duty to
care
to care for everyone and after all we've
been through
all america has accomplished all the
years that we've stood as a beacon to
the world
we cannot let ourselves remain divided
but we have to vote go to iwillvote.com
fl you can still request your
vote by mail ballot the deadline is
october 24th
request your ballot if you have it
already mail it or drop it in one of the
drop boxes today
look i'm tired of us all walking around
with our heads down as if there's
nothing we can do this is the united
states of america
there's not a single thing beyond our
capacity
nothing we've ever decided to do we've
not accomplished
when we've done it together i remember
when we were kids
you had to learn about the famous speech
john
kennedy made about going to the moon
everybody remembers the different pieces
of it the part i remember my colleagues
used to kid me in the senate
when i was there when asked yeah
answering the unasked question why was
he doing it
he said because we refuse to postpone
we refuse to postpone
one more day what's within our capacity
as americans to do
there's nothing beyond our capacity
there's no limit to our future
we got to stand up lift our heads up the
only thing that can tear america apart
is america itself
and he's well on the way trying to do
that
everybody knows who donald trump is i
don't know who we
are who we are
we choose hope over fear unity over
division
science over fiction and yes truth over
lies
we can do this folks i promise you but
you got to vote
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops thank you for
listening you're a very patient audience
thank you
appreciate it thanks
i wish i could shake all your hands
every time i used to walk out of my
grandpa finnegan's house up in scranton
pennsylvania
he yelled joey keep the faith and my
grandma when she's life [ __ ] no joey
spread it
let's go spread the faith thanks
everybody